Michelle welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I'm almost out of debt
yay and I'm getting ready to save my
emergency fund and I was hoping for
wisdom on how much I should save I'm in
a hundred percent commission job and
I've been in the role for nine years and
averaged around 120 to 140 growth and
that's pretty stable barring a recession
my expenses monthly are only about
$3,500 a month currently however once
I'm out of debt I would also like to buy
a home and I imagine that would include
some additional expenses but really just
wanted your wisdom on how much money you
think I should save in my emergency fund
well we know a minimum of 3,500 times 3
or 6 right mmhmm yeah exactly
that's our minimum and so I if you take
that time 6 we're talking about 27,000
right exactly so now do you think if you
wise with the home purchase and knowing
that that will you know with all the
expenses that even come beyond the
mortgage that will probably raise my
monthly expenses a bit do you think it'd
be wise to save a little bit more
wouldn't hurt you know I you could start
with 20 and then just say okay after I
buy the house I'm gonna bump it to 30
okay I'd be okay to bring it the point
is just have an umbrella and then you
know if you decide you want a bigger
umbrella you upgrade your umbrella
I like that I like that you just gave me
permission to do that so I was thinking
that but I thought well they would want
me to save the whole thing first I
better do that well yeah you know it's
it's not you never mess up you know very
very no one calls this show and goes
Dave I have too much money I don't know
what to do that never happens here you
know so you can't ever mess up by having
too much but but I'm just trying to
stage this in a little bit because you
know obviously the more we throw at this
emergency fund the longer it takes you
to save your down payment get the house
yeah and I want to buy that house
exactly exactly so I'm willing to crank
it down to two
and that's that's you know that's a good
solid emergency fund for somebody making
120 with no bills and then okay that has
$3,500 a month expenses that's solid and
then then you could just move up a
little and give yourself a little more
comfort after you get into the house
great well I like that if I'm really
looking forward to seeing you at the
smart conference on the 24th
oh yeah we're heading that way we'll be
there before you know it hey look
forward to it thank you very much